[Music]
[Music]
what will you do without freedom
will you fight
i
speak out and you may be banned from
youtube
be silent and you'll keep your channels
at least for a while
and working in your cubicle many years
from now
would you be willing to trade all the
days from this day to that
for one chance just one chance
to come back here and tell the photies
the pfizers the madonnas that they may
try and force the mandates
but they'll never take our freedom
guys
no i know i know we heard you william
it's just
it's we get the call of it the work aye
it's got a 0.3
mortality rate point three that's that's
almost half yeah that's a point it's
only a 98 percent survival rate
and that warrants giving up your freedom
okay william
you're not taking into account what
about
omar grant
omicron
he doesn't even do well with colds no
last year he had a sinus infection he
was scratchy for weeks he was he was
going like that like
we're crying out loud they're rounding
up aussies and camps okay i hear they're
not that bad no they have air
conditioning they have wi-fi
they've got air conditioning it's muggy
enough as it is yeah i could use it i
can't believe my ears and what i'm
hearing from able-bodied young men yeah
william that's not the whole story now
is it i've got a pre-existing condition
hey and me too i forgot uh fibromyalgia
and social anxiety is no walk in the
park no it's crippling oh for creep sake
i said able bodies oh well your maple
butt needs a loaded word i mean you're
the one throwing able-bodied around
you're throwing around terms you need to
be more careful with your vocabulary
especially in a pandemic
all right okay what would be required
for you to fight for your freedom
i don't understand the question
okay all right it started with two weeks
to flatten the curves yeah
the masks actually i stopped today
william it was at first
no masks
but it there was only uh there was only
because of uh what is the ppe the ppe
shortage right sure right but but then
it was max then no mask but i and okay i
understand your point i guess you really
couldn't make it right okay so first it
was a look downs then it was masks
no masks and then uh masks then no masks
right then it was the vaccine in the
boosters like a seat yeah yep like i got
one okay so first it was lookdowns then
masks and no masks then two vaccines
plus a booster then vaccine mandates
then vaccine passports in europe in new
york required simply to go to grocery
stores restaurants movies then countries
started creating quarantine cats
don't forget don't forget uh don't
forget the uh
yeah that sounds about right yeah no i
think he got all of it he did that's yes
and you don't see any problem with this
you know it is what it is that's life
isn't that what would it take
what freedoms will you fight for when
you're dying in your bed
many years from now uh if we're part of
the 99.89
and if you're part of the 99.8 percent
dying in your bed many years from now
would you be willing to trade all the
days from this day to that for one
chance just one chance yes absolutely
yeah
full stop
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
speedy
[Music]
well i won't taste anything it's almost
like i have the covid well you made it
yourself i did
[Music]
self burning hot tea i blame uh mr james
lipton yeah he's not the same guy behind
the tea but i got hey look it's a happy
day today i know it was a happy day
yesterday but yesterday when we were
talking with you the deal was announced
but it wasn't finalized now elon musk
it's it's agreed upon purchasing twitter
yes absolutely baby
which uh by the way before you can
follow me on the twitter at escrider
just crossed one and a half million
which i didn't even notice i didn't even
know i was on there it's weird how
follower accounts have gone up recently
yes they have in the last days
specifically the last day specifically
you can follow gerald at g morgan junior
don't know why he has a horrible handle
and dave landout
landau dave that's your official
introduction everyone shut up so we have
sean king on the show today
i'm excited yeah really
dr king
jr is he a doctor yeah he has a dream oh
that he's actually a black guy i said
he's a doctor of blackness yes he's a
doctor of
the only ginger
well no they're albino black guys but i
mean the only white guy ginger who's a
black guy so
we do have cheese we should be nicer
since we have him on the show we're glad
that he had the arena we have him on the
show today we'll be talking about here's
one thing i want to uh point out
everyone's talking about okay elon musk
and twitter sure
uh
what i always
look to and and i want you guys to to
watch for you know i've always said this
where i don't want you guys to look to
my arguments if i make them
i want you to learn how to create your
own arguments that's why we try and make
all of the references available at light
earthquaker.com uh the link will be in
the description
you should be the pinned comment but now
we have pinned comment uh competitions
so uh it's in the description uh i try
and make them available so that you can
if nothing else learn not how to think
learn how to learn people learn
differently that's why you see boys they
don't do well
in grade school they don't do well in
high school but they tend to blow women
out of the water on the sats or do
significantly better and the reason for
that is not that one is smarter or
dumber as far as men and women the
reason for it is that men are now
allowed to with the sats study
how in a way that they effectively learn
everyone learns a little bit differently
i did not learn very well in school so i
try and provide you resources and one
thing that i would encourage you to
always do
is look for the reaction away from the
puck
and what do i mean by that well
people have talked about this with
acting you know it's it's reacting okay
it's not that elon musk has purchased
twitter don't look to the you know the
uh the touchdown dance you see that's
fun we'll do some of that but ask
yourself why one side is so furious and
ask yourself is it consistent with when
they've been outraged in the past to me
what's more telling is not the purchase
is not the victory dance
is the left freaking out melting down
losing their minds and the why
because nothing has changed yet
the only information that we have is
elon musk has purchased twitter okay
it's been agreed upon
and that he has said well he said he's
going to get rid of spam bots we should
all be on board with so no one's
outraged about that he's going to verify
all humans well okay no one should be
mad about that
and he said he wants more transparency
no one should be mad about that and that
free speech is the bedrock
of a functioning democracy of a free
society and he said that it will be more
free
that's the only information we have
available right now why is only one side
freaking out
why is only when people say it's not
left or it's not right do you see people
on the right
freaking out this the freak out i would
argue is people are now expecting
not different treatment the exact same
kind of treatment as everyone else
because for a long time there's been an
imbalance of power for reference see
every single jack dorsey interview
whether it's on joe rogan or look at the
the prio whatever i can't pronounce her
name but probably not going to work
there anymore
at twitter with tim poole
the reaction and the why is what's most
telling to me so
let me ask you this why do you think
there's this meltdown that's obvious but
what do you think is going to change at
twitter that's the question of the day
comment below
with elon musk and the ownership do you
expect big changes or do you think it's
going to be
more of the same i don't think it's
going to be a monumental shift i think
what's going to happen is just i'm going
to get fewer suspensions people like us
are going to get fewer suspensions go
and get fewer infractions i hope that
they lift the algorithmic throttling
which we don't know with twitter but
obviously it was baked into the page at
facebook and they let us know and then
with youtube they let us know that these
things were happening twitter we really
haven't been all that involved with for
a long time it's just kind of tossing
stuff up and let the cards fall where
they may but we're going to be talking
about that and more and have sean king
gerald a at g morgan jr on the twitter
how are you sir i am well how are you
i'm okay every day i popped my rib out
yesterday after the surgery thing so i
don't know
i have this icy hot patch and uh it'll
fix a rib well it doesn't work because
all the nerves are killed since the
surgery i didn't know your vagina was
that high that's not nice
look at the profanity right away that's
a medical term what do you mean
profanity holy roller over here come on
language out loud yeah sailor monster
haggard i'm sorry show me your icy hot
patch again
yes i was doing it to be titillating
because that's what i do this is this is
the male equivalent to lingerie this
really gets the ladies revving well
you know
i look like e.t when he's an elliot when
they're all patched up and he's in that
little wooden
little frozen casket yes
icebox i'm just glad they switched all
the guns to walkie-talkies so you can
watch it with my style i know yeah
better yeah now what scared me as a
child was not so much the guns but the
tubes going down the road the suburban
area and then walking in like space man
and the dying alien yes yeah the
government trying to kill a reese's
pieces eating aliens yes exactly that
was more terrifying to me a
cross-dressing alien well that's we all
know alien or transvestite yes
dress it as a girl that'll trick
everybody oh i don't know if you know
this uh a funny fact fast fact about to
e.t if you look closely enough in that
closet scene you can see the coke under
drew bray moore's nose
she had a yeah night the night before
they're from the beginning
phone he said
phone now uh you can follow him at uh
landau dave and i will be uh doing some
dates them uh the last one before uh the
summer break is june 18th we will both
be together pikes peak center in
colorado springs that's june 18th and
he'll be in green bay saturday
liverpool.com tour big announcement for
the fall tour going to be some big
cities how are you dave good ahoy i'm
good i got almost a thousand twitter
followers in the last days really not
even kidding no mine's shot up too i
have no is that what happened i'm not
kidding like not even kidding i told
johnny boy before the show was just like
hey uh oh my gosh what's going on you
guys should know this i know social
media very well as far as the algorithms
and what's going on politically and i
had to learn this but i really i'm a
very private person personally so i
don't really like social media so i
don't pay attention to followers that's
the last thing i look at is follower
accounts so i guess i guess mine shot up
too and you guys can help uh continue
shooting it up at uh uh at s crowder
shooting up like drew barrymore when she
was 10 years old i'm glad she cleaned on
right
it was tylenol yes no it was coke yeah
that was in her book when she was 11
when she was 11. seriously yeah yeah and
then when she gave her acceptance speech
at the at the oscars she was going oh i
just i couldn't ask for a better family
i'm like a family that let you do coke
at 11.
well i mean yeah my cousins my girl
cousins they couldn't even wear makeup
yeah i couldn't even stay up till
midnight no watch movies she thought she
could fly at 11. yeah that must have
been awesome she's at studio 54 doing
rails and i'm like can i watch an
r-rated movie yeah
it's like yeah yeah drew just uh go just
have mr halston drive you home
you're gonna have a great talk show when
you grow up yes
uh all right therapy is included before
we get to the because that's the bulk of
today elon musk twitter the reaction
sean king and the fallout and there's
more to it than just hey yay oh we're
mad um
the left is going to need to find some
comfort somewhere obviously as they they
melt down um we know that but uh um
these mentally stable children and this
comes i think we got from tick tock
uh
i i don't i i don't know what's going on
here
every thruple
is made up of these three audios
audios
hello boy
welcome here he comes sid
here comes the man
hello we're using that term a little
loosely these days taxpayer
[Music]
okay they said thruple thrupple is
supposed to be like a three-way couple
right and they said it includes all of
these audios is this a term are you
familiar with it honestly no no i swear
to you i just learned the word okay well
just now and audios
yeah i don't know what that means does
that mean members of the and then
they're saying here comes the boy and
they show uh a girl who looks like sid
from toy story and then an overweight
male and then a uh that uh
i mean someone who looks like a
the the skinny version of the comic book
guy from the simpsons but in yoga pants
what is going on what is happening here
this was released as though it was
informational education from the left
can someone please comment below i know
i'm just not i feel like i'm that old
man who's out of touch throuple audio
and the i don't know what's happening i
know what a threshold is i knew that i
knew that yeah so we have not heard the
term audios before have you no but i i
saw that the audience were different by
the way i took offense that they didn't
have any kind of fun song for the tax
paying man did you see that
i don't understand why they included a
tax paying me i don't know but they were
making fun of him
oh is that what it was maybe a little
bit they were mocking the tax they had
this like eloquent song at the end you
know and then at the beginning yes the
boy these were all stupid god forbid we
have anyone who supports your dead
weight in this society
what an
awful terrible world can we can somebody
buy tick tock and blow it up literally
well i think china owns it it's gonna be
hard to outbid
can we if you want china to blow it up
just have a few uh uyghur profiles put
on there
that'll be shut down quickly no kidding
wasn't it trump who said that they had
to have corporate ownership in the
united states they had to have a company
that they partnered with in the us was
that trump who did that and tried to
stop tick tock from taking over then
they partnered with jeff bezos
washington post well i think mike
actually is
even worse oh bill gates i thought it
was microsoft i don't know if the deal
if somebody let us know did they bill
gates is he uh has he uh had the baby
yet or is he still he's he's about to
pop almost
almost getting close
i'm excited he's gonna leave it one
million dollars that's what he said he's
eaten
so
let's set this up here it's uh obviously
official elon musk purchased twitter for
uh 44 billion dollars now we were
yesterday on air and brian stelter was
worried about this happened yesterday
around the same time around 10 45 where
he was speculating remember i said to
you guys look look he's only presenting
one side when he was speculating
yesterday at 10 45 he's going are there
are they going to lose users because of
uh you know it being the wild west super
straight and then
then he uh
had time to reflect
and later after we were off air i said
well is he going to find balance and
look at both points of view yeah this is
the issue with cnn again it's look to
the why don't look at what's being said
look at what's not being said he had
time to reflect upon it we've seen an
increase in users on twitter you've seen
a lot of people sign up right now you've
seen the stock price go up it's very
clear how the market has spoken
now watch cnn and super heterosexual
brian stelter uh speak in the face of
all hard data look who knows i i think
that's a that's a that's a meaning an
example of a broader question for
twitter which is always goes broad
uh
if you get invited to something there
are no rules where there is total
freedom uh forever everybody freedom do
you actually want to go to that party or
are you can decide to stay home and
that's a question for twitter users some
twitter users might love the idea
there's going to be absolutely no
moderation and no rules at all others
might not want to be anywhere near that
am i am i crazy matt no no you're right
and what what happened to the
advertising i mean if there's no
moderation or little moderation do the
advertisers stay away what does that do
to the the business prospects for
twitter itself oh all this talk about
parties probably a stelter in his fields
he's having flashbacks to all those
parties he didn't get invited to it
towson that's true don't worry he's he's
got his own see how he presents that
some people would love uh you know some
people might love no rules and anarchy
in danger look there are already rules
it's called the law you can't threaten
someone with death unless they're
conservative like we've had then they
don't get removed there are laws that
exist they want additional moderation
something else that's being said there
what will happen with the advertisers
this is something i don't know how much
inside baseball i'm allowed to discuss
here but with youtube okay i'll discuss
this with youtube i haven't really spent
that much time or effort into twitter
because you know i knew it was just back
then it was just sort of you know
running in place
with youtube uh this happened i want to
explain to you when they are saying this
about advertisers uh there's some
what'll happen with advertisers what
they mean is they are going to try and
influence advertisers not the market the
market is spoken the users can speak and
then they want to try and change it and
manipulate it this happened with uh
youtube now for a long time i've run ads
on youtube and what i mean by that is
literally just taking videos in a very
low dollar amount but just so that we
could continually kind of get access to
more analytics run ads where we'll just
run a video you know it's a pre-roll
video ad before other videos and they
were approved before they were
disapproved and then sometimes they were
simultaneously disapproved and approved
but i've run at so i've been passed all
the checks though they cashed all the
checks yes either way so i've run ads on
youtube i have been an advertiser i've
also been a channel where advertisers
have run
their ads okay once upon a time
been demonetized for a very long time
please consider supporting
loudoutcrowder.com mug club uh that's we
do a whole we have a whole other
45 minutes today by the way also every
day monday through thursday 10 a.m
eastern notifications don't work
subscription bell doesn't work so just
tune in here and or go to rumble or mug
club okay
i hope elon musk buys youtube i do hope
that he might say that on here well
here's the thing his influence
might uh it might touch all these other
social media platforms that's what i'm
hoping because he'll have to compete but
i've been on both sides with youtube
okay so i have a little bit of insight
i've been an advertiser and an
advertisee i guess for lack of a better
term now
as someone who runs a channel and we
were being monetized i would say hey uh
is there a way to more effectively
target ads because for example on my
channel seth meyers is running as an ad
or something for glad is running as an
ad could i have i don't know let's say
companies like walther or like federal
ammunition or conservative companies
companies or even athletic companies
like under armour you know companies
that would at least be inoffensive to
most right-leaning people and they said
well we can't really do that i said well
why so because advertisers don't want to
advertise on on your well first off we
don't allow firearm companies and we
don't oh so you've eliminated half of
the pool we don't allow them to
advertise and then the other advertisers
don't want to advertise on your platform
that's not what advertisers want and i
said hold on a second
you're talking to an advertiser because
as an advertiser i would also like to
target content that is more relevant so
that my videos don't run on seth meyers
and stephen colbert you can't do that
either so they determine
who gets to advertise and then they
determine where you get to advertise and
then say well look advertisers are
afraid to run on this no you are the
advertiser friendly guidelines youtube
has three rules and this is the problem
with the lack of transparency they have
community guidelines
which are ever changing that's where you
get a strike right we get suspended if
gerald quotes the cdc shut up sorry then
there are advertiser friendly guidelines
which determines whether you're
monetized or not now this is really just
another form of guidelines from youtube
it's not actually coming from
advertisers you want to tell me that
there aren't advertisers who would want
to reach the half of america that elect
presidents i'm sorry usually not the
free most fair election of all time
uh and then they have borderline content
guidelines
which no one has really actually
explained and no one knows who the
advisors are so that's the issue they
run into when they say advertisers what
kind of advertisers are going to want to
run well the ones who aren't intimidated
by you you're trying to again censor
culturally as cultural marxism the
advertisers you're trying to make them
afraid they're not afraid to advertise
here
they're not advertisers are not saying
to youtube you better not allow donald
trump the the most popular president
until joe biden is obviously the most of
course popularist president the most is
popular right uh we don't want the most
popular president of all time anywhere
on that platform we're going to pull our
ads you think they're saying that
no you think smith and wesson's saying
that
do you think you think uh bass pro is
saying that
no it comes from youtube and it used to
come from twitter and now this is a dog
whistle they use the term all the time
or they say dog when you say you know
when you say taxpayer what you really
mean is white that's your dog whistle or
maybe i mean taxpayer like the thrupple
did but when you say what are the
advertisers gonna do that's a call out
to them to say huh huh huh make sure we
still have an advantage with these big
multimedia
corporate conglomerates brian stelter
doesn't stand to snowball doesn't stand
a stelter's ball's chance in hell
of surviving on equal playing field you
think he's going to go tit-for-tat for
with someone like you on a battle of
wits of course not no he's not and so
they go after the well they might go
tits well
elon musk knows this is too sure right
he knows that this is happening and he
has got a plan for it that's why he said
he wants to get away from advertisers
but let me say something really quickly
you addressed
that he said that there was a problem
with you know two no rules right you
said no no we have the rules you know
what a second scary word was that he was
trying to make you go oh my gosh more
freedom yeah he said there's freedom
and that was a scary proposition for him
and hopefully for you in his mind oh my
god there's freedom there could be
freedom we can't have that wait hold on
i'll tell you about the freedom of
choice that's just when it comes to
killing somebody else are you freedom of
choice when it comes to uh what kind of
car you can drive no because of carbon
emissions are you free of a choice when
it comes to what kind of taxes no
because we need to tax rush more are you
freedom of choice when it comes to what
kind of content is allowed on platforms
no because we only be protected from
hate speech so your freedom of choice on
nothing except abortion and funyuns yeah
who do you buy the car off of by the way
that you uh you want to drive to protect
the environment yeah the nazi that that
bought tesla yes yeah listen i'll help
you out give me your tesla right now and
i will relieve you of the burden right
yes give your tesla to a republican well
no rules and freedom simply means rules
for the left yeah that's exactly yeah
rules they get to you can enforce that
that's what they want it means you can't
threaten to kill everyone all the time
and get away with it or doxxing no no
that's journalistic integrity yes that's
why we go to people's houses who are
involved in it it was publicly private
information all right so look let me
just read some quotes uh musk publicized
uh one of his own previous interviews on
twitter and i'll give you some a montage
of just the best meltdowns so he wrote
free speech is the bedrock of a
functioning democracy and twitter is a
digital town square where matters vital
to the future of humanity are debated i
also want to make twitter better than
ever by enhancing the product with new
features making the algorithms open
source to increase trust defeating
spambots and authenticating all humans
here's the thing if i have a problem
with what he just said i'm not going to
be stupid enough to just say to
transparency to increase trust i'll act
like it sounds good
and then try and frame in a way that
maybe favors my point of view the left
again they're so they're so used to
fearing it to
not fearing any kind of accountability
that they don't even realize they should
fake like transparency to increase trust
sounds like a good thing they can't even
do that so unsurprisingly i'm sure
you've seen some of these but some of
these are gems uh the left is not
processing for some for a group obsessed
with mental health boy they are mental
they are not processing this in a
mentally healthy way
when the richest guy in the world takes
over the most important social media
platform that's just not a winning
formula to me it reminds me of old bond
movies where you know dr evil and guys
like that or goldfinger we're going to
take over the media there is a problem
with this idea of free speech and that
is where is the limit
free speech has the ability to incite
some really horrific and hateful things
like for instance an insurrection
twitter will not be the only cesspool um
it will spill over and facebook will get
worse you'll see trump and others having
their facebook accounts restored you'll
see major social media networks unwind
uh to start grappling with the problems
of disinformation and threats okay
by the way i love voices like dr evil as
opposed to jeff bezos who purchased the
washington post and literally looks like
a bond villain hold on
sorry so time out
built a ball's rocket like dr evil yeah
exactly dr evil comes in and says more
freedom yeah that's what dr evil has
done that's what every bond villain has
done i'm going to hold the world hostage
unless you let everyone speak freely
yeah
i want one million dollars are you
serious what they're saying they're
afraid of was already in place it was
your guys running every social media
every news outlet out there safe for
maybe one and independent content
creators on youtube that was it you guys
were the bond villain yeah no that's
exactly right yes no keep in mind too
we're going to get to jin saki now and
now all of a sudden they want to talk
about section 230 oh they want to talk
about the changes
just i just want you to remember that
we've been here since uh talking about 2
30 since 2004 ever 2015 and i've been
here on youtube since 2006 louder with
crowders and someone since 2009. so just
go back i just point you to the record
now let's go to the naacp usually a
bastion of freedom
uh they put out a statement that said mr
musk free speech is wonderful hate
speech is unacceptable oh boy
disinformation misinformation and hate
speech have no place on twitter let me
just let me just break this down for you
for a couple of cnn yes
so what a where's how are they
delineating free speech is wonderful
hate speech is unacceptable by the way
one of the first changed my minds i ever
did when i didn't have a permit in
vermont was a sandwich board that hate
speech is is not real no it's not
changed my mind
and no one could make the case hate
speech isn't a thing in the united
states
now if you look at countries where hate
speech has been incorporated and this is
why when people say why don't you just
focus on policies
this is one of the most important issues
i will tell you this the freedom
of americans to access information and i
will say also for me the idea that
gender doesn't exist that male and
female or fundamentally interchangeable
are the two most important issues if
those go away guess what everything else
goes you destroy the family unit and you
destroy the amer the american public's
ability to simply access information
imagine if back in the day there was
someone in front of the public library
like huh you no no that little bent back
paper clip saying you can't use word
processor or whatever the hell it was
so free speech is wonderful hate speech
is unacceptable define hate speech naacp
disinformation misinformation what is
that
well we know we have examples we do you
quoting the cdc that is i guess it would
be on flew down that was misinformation
or dis i have no idea us reporting on
actual voter addresses and going there
misinformation and voter rolls being
changed which were was confirmed to us
by a local registrar when we called them
removed as disinformation misinformation
what they what i saw it with my own eyes
yes
no no dave no you think you saw him
right you miss saw in fairness it was
only 100 of the houses i visited
i'm surprised in detroit they actually
had houses where you were oh yeah i'm
sorry i mean houses we thought something
was up intersections fields fences so
disinformation misinformation hate
speech have no place on twitter so
they've now declared right uh just just
full stop there's no place on twitter
for something that hasn't been defined
and by the way is an ever moving target
this is what they don't want to go away
i want to be clear about what this is
it's not just oh you have free speech
pepe meme no look at what the left is
saying look at why they're upset and
look at how they're trying to frame it
that's where you will glean the most
information this is what the naacp also
said do not allow 45 to return to the
platform well now we have a partial
definition oh
oh
the former president the president of
the united states president donald trump
he is a hate speaker
under the only president to go into
office pro-gay marriage ever in the
history of the united states did more
for black americans than the black
americans he let our senior hall win the
celebrity apprentice for god's sake well
it's true
and he even did the
that was the entire that was a reality
series equivalent of my black my black
friend yes
don't you see a letter sidio wed and
he's talentless he sucks
look how much i must love black people
do not allow 45 to return to the
platform do not allow twitter to be uh
become a petri dish for hate speech or
falsehoods that subvert our democracy oh
god got it subvert our democracy do you
mean like billions of dollars in damages
black lives matter who then use the
money and ran off to buy multi-million
dollar estates and non-profits that
closed up shop and didn't really exist
you guys were all led astray by the
grifters with black lives matter just to
be clear it was a bunch of frauds and
then a bunch of white women saying yes
too
subvert our democracy oh you mean a
couple hundred thousand people
protesting at the capitol with uh let's
say a couple hundred people who uh
only one was shot and it wasn't a cop as
opposed to the dozens of cat well the
hundreds of casualties over the course
of the summer of hey how about this how
about this
misinformation
is the mayor held accountable
in seattle or portland
when they say it's peaceful it's the
summer of love
that's verifiably false right when
you're talking about chas three people
shot in a span of weeks
do you move that person
oh you removed president donald trump
for saying hey
it's time to it's time to make your
voices heard go and protest peacefully
at the capitol league what about the
people who verify hey do you remove the
guy on cnn the reporter with gay face in
front of the car ablaze saying
mostly
mostly flameless mostly peaceful we can
see the misinformation with our own eyes
the problem is for the left they've just
been able to say it doesn't matter what
you see it doesn't matter exactly what
you're experiencing it doesn't matter
what the data says we're going to lie to
you and we're going to remove the people
who call us on our lives that's what
they're terrified of losing
how about the guys who said white
supremacists guns people down in kenosha
this isn't new by the way no we'll be
remembering remember when the media you
may not remember this dave because you
weren't um i mean you weren't really
you weren't really conservative back
then but the fairness uh when people
talk about the uh the fairness doctrine
i believe is what it was called
liberals had abcm they had all of
television right they had fm radio they
had pretty much everything at that point
and then you have this guy named rush
limbaugh who use an outdated right was
thought to be an archaic method am radio
and then because it was an alternative
sort of like you saw with social media
you're seeing it happen all over again
they said you know what we're going to
take over this medium and it became the
most popular show on earth and then
the left said we need to make sure that
there is equal time on am radio remember
there was that air america or radio
america with uh janine garofalo and al
franken
and it didn't work and it failed so
because they failed when they were on
equal footing on a medium that they they
wanted nothing to do with they weren't
happy having all of networks they
weren't happy having all of cable they
weren't happy having all of fm they said
we need to guarantee equal time on am
radio because no one wants to listen to
us this is a constant pattern in the
open market of ideas and i know that
both sides say i'm right they suck but
if you look at it historically in the
open market of ideas the left always
loses ground yeah
then you see it with the internet
you see it with facebook you see it with
youtube you see it with twitter there
were no conservatives on youtube when i
was there at 2006 2009 and then when
there started to be a momentum shift
they changed the algorithms and it was
the same thing with twitter and it was
the same thing with facebook
just like am radio this has always
happened all right uh protecting our
democracy i'm reading more from the
naacp is of the utmost importance
especially as the midterm elections
approach mr musk lives are at risk and
so is american democracy i'm sorry look
naacp
[ __ ]
hugh with a ph of course different word
yeah just like the french that's the
french word for seal p-h-o-q-u-e
[ __ ] that's true yeah yeah he mentioned
the midterm elections i would like to
just kind of summarize we gonna lose yes
that was a quicker way that he could
have just said it
speaking of elections uh twitter
employees donate 98.7 percent for one
side oh guess which one oh no uh i'm
going to guess uh ralph nader yeah
yeah the green party no yes the green
party yeah jill stein yes and that that
who was that witch who ran for anyway
so uh they aren't the only ones who are
afraid that musk
will not be silencing hate
uh sean king
before deactivating his account and he
deactivated it and then he came back on
just to be clear you're just admitting
though by all of this in a day that
you've done nothing but take over social
media and now you're so upset that
there's a small possibility it might not
go your way right i know it's insane
just your reaction is like but the thing
we made everybody guilty about they're
taking
we control the information if you take
this away we woke up
how are we gonna lie to everybody if you
lie the problem is they were so used to
being able to do it and no one being
able to see it that they don't even
realize now this is happening and people
can see it like oh wait we're not
supposed to say that part out loud
someone at the naacp should have
proofread it been like yeah i don't know
if you should tip your hand saying uh 45
shouldn't be allowed back and elon musk
you need to affect the midterms i think
we should maybe couch it in like i don't
know hey just just say hate speech
hard workers well it's like you said
that with it was it it was in front of
our eyes like they got that good at it
where it's like it's a peaceful protest
and it's like there's four car lots on
fire and you're like yeah yeah but
besides that they were already on fire
before we got it yeah come on it's uh
who knows who started that right
[Laughter]
quit your whining but i'm literally
being raped come on don't be a baby it's
new york come on defund the police
whatever yeah the police are bad which
by the way everyone has had to do an
about face on it before i get to shun
king that's an interesting point to
defund the police hey look we all talk
you can't find common ground and say i
think police need better training okay i
think that police need to be paid for
their time training uh because they're
overworked right so they part of their
work needs to be time training we've
talked about submission methods so that
they can de-escalate we've talked about
actually being physically fit so that
they don't have to reach for the gun but
all of these solutions on which we would
perhaps find common ground require
more funding not less what do you think
is going to happen when you defund the
police they're stressed they're
overworked they're lurking working
longer hours they don't have time to
train they're going in they've got a
vein popping out of their forehead like
stressed eric well you end up with all
the cities that have defunded the police
good luck so speaking of defunding the
police sean king before deactivating his
twitter account he tweeted at its root
elon musk wanting to purchase twitter is
not about left versus right that's how
you know they're about to lie no when
they say it's not left versus right it's
not conservative versus liberal yeah it
is it's not about race but it's all
about race right it's about oh you oh
that was
sorry he wrote it's foreign white slac
parenthesis me power it's about me power
white powder
horrible film the man was raised in a in
apartheid by a white nationalist he's
upset that twitter won't allow white
nationalists to target and harass people
that's his definition of free speech by
the way for reference here's sean king
as a child yeah the black activist
wow
he's an eggshell
he looks like halfway between urkel and
stefan yes but he's also dipped and kid
from kid and play yes
that's a white kid there are more
pictures by the way he's awake
if you were going by
like let's say you were well you can
also go by his parents who are white
well if you were painting your kitchen
black let's say yeah and you showed up
and it was painted this right which
would be like uh
yeah this is a problem that's eggshell
friend yeah we cannot do this actually i
distinctly wanted black because i'm a
wiccan and this is going to throw
anyone paid their kitchen back i don't
know
why would anyone catch you why would
anyone answer
now this morning looks like he's
returned to twitter and he's already
back to talking crap he said uh when
someone said someone reported on the
fact that his twitter account had been
removed language he said
you wish motherfu
i didn't delete my account you literally
made that up i was getting death threats
and hack attempts from your buddies who
stormed the capital and had to make it
more secure i'm right here and you are a
white supremacist but here's the thing
he did deactivate his account and
notified everyone though yes he did so
uh mr king actually uh dr king jr junior
junior wanted to uh clarify his comments
and so we're really excited about the
show he reached out to us to see if he
could explain it himself and actually
you've had a lot of you you've wanted
i've spoken with him before yes you
wanted to interview mr king i did yeah
and i actually have to go
to the control room for some work so uh
uh on the line now do we have them we
have uh the man himself uh dr sean king
jr
[Music]
all right this is going to be fun i
can't believe he's gonna be on our show
is he is do we do we lose him or is he
still there where he is he's there we're
getting the connection now okay you're
bringing it up awesome
awesome
i hope he's not offended sir
okay all right let's get in here all
right we got dave okay you there got you
i really really is he there
yes i am here
assalamu alaikum
uh good morning uh yeah thank you for
calling in mr king i know you're a busy
man oh no i am not
okay i'm not very busy at all i had i
was sitting here waiting
oh well
either way thank you uh so last night
you tweeted that elon musk was a fake
african uh a white supremacist and then
you deleted your account i deleted my
account that is correct
psych
psyc
i am back
and i encourage all my brothers and
sisters to as well fake leave
like i did and then
fake leave
come back
then fake leave again triple d bombay up
in this [ __ ]
gordon bombay okay so you didn't just uh
i don't know the word re
anyway so but some people have said that
you're a fake african i mean i just want
to put that out there at least that
you're pretending to be
african-american is that true
please
i do black things
okay that sounds a little no that's not
anything we're racist that's not an
answer at all are you black i got like
dave i got like five kids
okay you're dodging the question oh i
got scars on my face
from the struggle of my nine acre estate
what struggle
uh uh well i struggled to tie a proper
winsor knot while sailing i also found
out that you don't use a windsor knot
when sailing
gotta do a slip knot so damn i i i
nearly got knocked off my shooter holmes
gangster [ __ ]
okay well unless you've been on a boat
you've been on a boat lately there's
spiders though there's a lot of spiders
i think that's true someone told me get
a mint plant it repel them i found a
damn spider in the mint plant don't do
[ __ ] you have a mint plant
that's very
interesting i would have called that no
i wouldn't have that's very okay well
anyway okay so let's just
let's be let's just put it is there any
black dna in you at all i have seen
and i cannot stress this enough dave
okay i have seen medea's christmas
11 times
so no
i sleep in a wave cap
last night i messed around and got me a
triple-double
it's hard out here for a pimp we was
kings i'm frequently late
jerry curls okay that was just a mix of
pop culture and yes so okay so uh you
know what i knew you weren't black
come on dave look you invited me on the
show i just i'm here to promote my i'm
here to plug my new book man
okay
do it says sounds
say that again say that again look you
know it's just not right to sandbag me
like this i came here to promote my book
and you know you guys are all just
bagging on me what your voice
your voice okay you have a book
well i haven't written it yet
thanks for calling
[Music]
you know that was very surprising
especially at the the end he just he
kind of broke you know and finally let
him
himself come out you know i always
wanted to meet him but i don't know that
was ridiculous i i think
how did that go guys i just uh yeah no
you you're gonna love it am i i don't i
i don't think i i feel like you might be
some sort of imposter really yes well
that's a syndrome imposter syndrome yeah
i don't know he he did say jerry curl so
i guess oh that's a black thing he said
messed around and got a triple double
and so i'm like oh yeah hip hop he's
definitely heard an ice cube song right
so we can we can
did mama
mama make the breakfast with no pork
yeah with no hog and no i believe there
was no smog right ah well they is from
los angeles they do the smog check yeah
i'm not sure if he had used his ak or
not there may have been a peaceful
protest yeah i have no idea
everybody calls uh uh sean king a pimp
he didn't say he grabbed a nine on his
urban show i don't know that's weird i
have no idea all right yeah he's uh he
did say gordon bombay so that
that well it's not called puck time yeah
that's a little scary because i don't
know i mean i guess have you not seen uh
impoverished black american youth in
south central la playing uh rollerblade
hockey in the basketball court yeah
that's why it seems you know suspect
also sailing he's a sailor hey
i don't have anything for that one i
don't know
he was sailing
well it could be it could be you know
therapy it's like it's like it's contact
yeah it's getting over your fear well
yeah he wasn't good at sailing he's not
insane
yeah he said that he had trouble tying
certain knots
and then he got hit right with the sails
and he's not black beard bobby's
obviously not black well he's also
afraid of spiders so you guys can
commiserate on that yes yes yeah
also he's terrified of magic now yeah
our easy trick
you a wizard is what
so
also uh other reactions we have ari
melber from msnbc and this is really
telling where he doesn't realize what
he's saying but he's saying it again
watch what the left don't this is why we
always use leftist sources so if you
check the references and by the way
smash the like button if you guys use
the references megan kelly uses the
reference i didn't interview
if you use them if you appreciate that
we provide them otherwise we're just
going to stop providing them but we
always use neutral or liberal sources
because i'm far more interested in
hearing what uh the opposing point of
view to my own i'm right-leaning i'm
very open about that i'm very open about
my bias i'm far mentioned what they're
saying because it's more telling so ari
melber on msnbc here he lists the
problem with social media censorship
the irony train's not stopping here you
own all of twitter or facebook or what
have you
you don't have to explain yourself you
don't even have to be transparent you
could secretly ban
one party's candidate or all of its
candidates wow it's nominees or you
could just secretly turn down the reach
of their stuff and turn up the reach of
something else and the rest of us might
not even find it
philosophically clear open-minded helper
okay let me be clear here just for a
second he's saying a member of one party
just to be clear the guy he's talking
about as though it's donald trump who
now owns twitter
is the guy who spearheaded the modern
electric car has done more for the green
movement than any other human being
alive right now and by the way the man
who creates the car
that your party told people to buy
with skyrocketing gas prices so that's
who he's talking about is the evil
villain who's gonna throttle the party
meanwhile at the twitter board and if
you look at people not only at twitter
not only abc at nbcbs msnbc you look at
netflix you have actual members of the
clinton administration the obama cabinet
these people sit on the boards elon musk
is an actual
african-american guy
who invented the most select uh
successful electric car of all time
friends he was like harry where'd you
get your talking points well it's what
twitter said they were already doing
yeah well i got it from the afraid
i got it from june of 2020. yes it's
called it's in a file called the plan
[Laughter]
dnc plan oh crap sorry no no the rnc
plan now we had to change some oh yeah
we just changed one letter
he's using
the dial or like he's you know getting
brian stelter started yeah he added two
lines
yes it aren't now yeah so that is so
terrible i feel really bad for that guy
too he's like out there like guys this
is a problem like yes thank you finally
it
that's a bad thing if somebody can do
that who would have thought he's like
this couldn't have happened before yeah
several months later this is exactly
what happened well just to give you
another example how many times have you
heard us talk about section 230 my half
asian lawyer bill richmond we've
discussed this many times we've been in
many we've been embroiled in many a
legal battle
and the left act talked about his name
he talked about it with senator ted cruz
incredibly important yes and rand paul
well here's jen sackey when asked about
the twitter situation giving a
non-answer but again it's very telling
the president has long been concerned
about the power of large social media
platforms uh what they have that power
they have over our everyday lives has
long argued that tech platforms must be
held accountable for the harms they
cause he's been a strong supporter of
fundamental reforms to achieve that goal
including reforms to section 230
enacting anti-trust reforms requiring
more transparency and more and he's
encouraged uh that there's bipartisan
interest in congress uh in terms of what
hypothetical policies uh might happen
i'm just not going to speak to that at
this point okay so let me just inform
you a little bit uh if you're not
necessarily where section 230 is what
provides protections to a lot of these
social media companies because it treats
them similar to a utility right where
it's a digital sort of town square so
the idea is they're not held liable for
anything that is said on their platform
as opposed to say the new york times or
washington post would be held liable if
there's any kind of uh you know
defamation slander that's written there
because they're a publisher okay
so 230 gives them those protections now
we have complaints we have talked about
this for a long time and my solution has
always been these social media platforms
get a choice
are you a platform or are you a
publisher if you're a platform it's very
simple because a lot of people say well
if you declare them all to be uh
platforms and you hold them liable then
you'll get rid of message boards you'll
get no no no if facebook which indul
enjoys safe harbor status or twitter or
youtube they enjoy the status equivalent
to a public utility okay
they then if they decide to enjoy that
status cannot censor or remove anyone
based on point of view or favor any
point of view
outside of the law the laws are very
clear things like death threats things
like active calls to physical violence
for example things that might actually
be labeled slander defamation those
people will be held liable but not the
actual platform itself now if they just
so they have a choice with 230 this is
our solution
or they can decide that they are a
publisher
for example if youtube says this content
is allowed but this content is not or
even if they say this content is allowed
to be deemed monetizable this content is
not or if twitter says this information
is allowed but this information you are
now a publisher like the new york times
or washington post you just have to pick
and you get to pick now when she says
reform to 230 and this is my problem
when people say common ground it's
usually [ __ ]
and this comes as someone who's done
changed my mind and who is who has had
more civil discussions with leftists
than arguably
any other host that i know of here in
conservative on conservative platforms
because i try i try and match intensity
and i try and give people the respect
that i would you know hope i'd receive
on their program i still tell you that
most common ground is [ __ ] because
that's how we believe
we approach section 230 them saying oh
there's bipartisan support they want
more regulation and to crack down on
companies for not removing points of
view enough there is no common ground
just because you're looking at a law
it's like two it's like saying we need
to find common ground on this murder law
yeah really okay yeah well we good so
look we all agree we need to do
something about this murder right yeah
we think it should be illegal see we
think it should be legal though
[Applause]
you know what it did it prevented
twitter from being sued when donald
trump's tax records were illegally
published right right but then by the
way the hunter biden story was a
violation of privacy well yes yes yes
because that that was obviously uh
stolen information i mean forgotten and
left somewhere
horrific crimes maybe four laptops is
that not a clear enough example yeah
donald trump
tax return illegally stolen leaked 10
days apart hunter biden story that was
legitimately obtained would have
affected the outcome of the election
every single swing state twitter decided
yes and no
that when you're talking about
democracies and midterms what they're
saying is we want to be able to continue
to do that hey has the left ever
apologize no has has the new york times
the washington post has cnn has msnbc
they then cover the hunter biden story
and say well it seems like this is
legitimate without saying hey we were
wrong in supporting the removal of a
story that would have directly affected
the outcome of the election hey that was
they never have to apologize that change
you know without even getting into
mail-in
voter errors fraud whatever you want to
call it we've covered that at length
without even getting into that
just that
just the hunter biden story let alone
pages like ours being throttled 90 i can
only imagine with other conservatives
just that is enough to tilt the vote and
change the history
of the united states
and all we want now is just say no more
of that
no more of that and they're acting like
it's it's it's the third reich okay well
to them it is yes it takes away all that
power yep
all that white power yeah that's what i
meant i'm sorry here we go it's the
white power you and your ed for a long
jacket listen we have an african
american that owns a big tech company
okay we are making progress charlize
theron no no
uh twitter employees have reacted and
which is fantastic
talman smith source at twitter provided
some reactions of the employees so here
are some quotes i feel like i'm going to
throw up good i hate him musk oh that's
wrong you're not supposed to hate you're
supposed to be gentle creatures twitter
workers i hate him musk why does he even
want this i can guess i feel like he's
this petulant little boy and that he's
doing this to troll we're just gonna let
everyone run amok
yeah and then robert reich would so fire
you just for fun yeah
i just walk in and be like hey guess
who's not eating yeah i don't know i
have a better idea dave and so does
governor greg abbott of the great state
of texas he's like hey elon you brought
every other company here why don't you
bring twitter here i would love for them
and he's in a wheelchair he is a
wheelchair that guy so robert reich
without yeah people don't even listen to
him
robert reich without even uh
seeing a hint of irony here um in that
he is bill clinton's former secretary of
labor
oh still alive too still he had these
takes in other words when someone who is
a former secretary of a president
one of the most corrupt ever the clinton
family you could argue the most corrupt
ever you could argue one could argue not
saying they killed multiple people
had he had some of these takes he said
anyone who is saying twitter's ban
violates the first amendment doesn't
know that twitter is a private company
and the first amendment protects
individuals against government that was
a year ago that was a year it didn't
take a year right that was his take a
year ago a little over right
now it's like what's a private company
okay great there you go should apply it
was a wrong take back then by the way
but well yes again just hold them to
their own standards surely nothing has
changed no now he says musk and his
apologists say if consumers don't like
what he does with twitter they can go
elsewhere but where else would consumers
go to po short messages that can reach
millions of people other than twitter
the free market inc well might i suggest
uh your your favorite uh public bathroom
stall
the free market increasingly reflects
the demands of big money come on
come on just be consistent robert you're
a hack yeah how about your anonymous
hyper sexual personal ads oh he is a
professor at berkeley he has millions of
followers i cannot believe people are
dumb enough to listen to this guy who
can't even be consistent with his own
opinions he's a professor at berkeley
though well that knows what they used to
say right if you were to say hey look i
think we need to reform a section 230
because these companies are very big and
they enjoy not only they lobby the
government but there are former
government officials who work here there
are people who donate 98 of their money
is the most powerful companies in the
world entirely to the democratic party
and we just think that they need to be
transparent and be holding the same
rules as other companies that enjoy
these benefits as public utilities and
they would serve the private platform
for the first time they care about
people that understand they care about
free enterprise and now immediately
okay we gotta do 230. well we've been
saying 234 years what do you want the
government to take control over
everything oh okay we get it bill
clinton's former secretary of labor
prick now i do understand why he's
scared the whole time he's five foot two
well yeah so he's scared of everything
the man started his own shadow it's like
peter pan where she's a shadow with the
pan flute and he's running
his little julie andrews
i just like that he's a secretary yeah
well not that kind of guy
he's probably that kind he didn't have
as much fun in the white house so um
held the bulls
look at what elon musk posted this
sounds like stalin reincarnated before
the purchase was announced he said i
hope that even my worst critics remain
on twitter oh because that is what free
speech means absolutely disgusting it's
just and it's terrifying
yeah i just broke out in a cold sweat oh
that's the icy hot patch that might be
it yeah it tricked me
i just always felt i was like who am i
stealth or is his tits wet no it's just
it's the icy oh oh really again
i'm in a meat sweat from
cracker barrel so uh
here's another uh uh quote from yahoo uh
from a twitter employee and to be fair i
wasn't able to find the original tweet
i'm going to trust that yahoo is an
authoritative source because why would
they lie but it's funny enough that i
wanted to include it and yahoo claims
it's real i understand yahoo's serious
yes yeah get it so here's a quote from
uh uh uh yahoo from someone who works at
twitter 50 billion spent on a social
media site when people are starving to
death this is the kind of insight that
look let me here's something that really
bothers me about this aside from
everything
50 billion spent on a social media site
when people are starving to death don't
you work at twitter
hey you're working in silicon valley
what are you doing for people starving
to death how much of your paycheck do
you give when you take your vacation are
you feeding the homeless
for some reason people just go when
someone's rich
why are you allowed to spend money on
anything other than other people's
problems well you're rich compared to
99.9 of population earth certainly the
people who are starving to death why are
you allowed to purchase i don't know
anything a coffee
urban outfitters your silly little
t-shirt that says uh do you know how i
don't like you because you're talking
huh or hot topic whatever the hell it is
that you do i don't know i just assume
you embody everything that i hate the
only language i speak is sarcasm yes
exactly well here's the thing elon 9
o'clock somewhere yeah elon musk just
gave every twitter shareholder an
opportunity to go and solve the problem
he just gave you 44 billion dollars
going and by the way elon musk 50
billion dollars ain't gonna mean all
that much to him so let's be clear 50
billion to him is comparatively uh maybe
to you what let's say you know the
average salary for people who work in
these tech companies is over a hundred
thousand dollars a year uh let's call it
150 000 a year okay so 50 billion of him
is maybe the equivalent to let's say 20
a year are you giving twenty thousand
dollars of your salary to
the poor
to starving people for some reason it's
only expected of people once they have a
certain and by the way if that's that's
the crossover where they are required to
do what you want in feeding the what's
the number
because if you talk to kids in
somalia you talk to kids in uganda guess
what they would probably make that
number well anyone who's making over uh
five dollars a month and i don't have
the numbers in front of me i'm giving
you a general figure because those
countries don't do very well financially
oh that's racist no no it's true what
are you doing to help them this is the
class warfare that they wage and it's a
brilliant way to constantly apply
standards to other people that they
never apply to themselves we see it with
free speech we see it with section three
uh three two three two thirty we see it
now with elon musk with his money by the
way with the other billions he was busy
creating the only viable electric car
that your folks told people to buy
wasn't gonna work with a prius it was a
glorified shopping cart with a battery
and every [ __ ] who couldn't drive
decided to have a secret meeting behind
our backs and say that they would buy
one yeah and by the way just so you know
when elon musk was shamed for not
sending six billion dollars to end world
hunger he replied if you can prove that
you can end world hunger for six billion
dollars i'll write the check well the
bluff was never called the problem is is
that's the immediate go-to to have you
know this fake moral uh ideology you
immediately go to okay why don't you
solve world hunger okay well the problem
is we're gonna throw relief rice out of
a helicopter but then all of the
warlords confiscated yeah and still
starve out their people there's so many
other third world problems that are just
caused that hunger than just the in
inability to get food no it does it's so
stupid there's so many layers of it and
it's like yeah why doesn't he give the
poor all this money same reason you do
that's the same reason they go is this
absurd hey why don't we just change from
fossil fuels to renewable here's a
five-page bill that i think covers all
of it i think you'll find all this yeah
i donate to a homeless shelter in
detroit and i donate to a special
olympics yeah and an animal place that's
what i do because that's what i can
afford to do right and it's like i can't
and i don't know maybe somebody just
keeps the money yeah i don't know if
they're corrupt i have these staff the
charities are this is there's again no
accountability their green new deal they
go they go we're gonna write a five page
is this the five page one or the 16
pages which bill was 16 pages
was five because you read it on air i
think it might have been 16 pages really
i don't think so i could be giving them
more credits but aoc in the squad said
you know what we think something needs
to be done about this uh needs to be
done about this climate crisis they
wrote and said uh we think you'll be uh
really happy with what we've provided i
think you'll be thrilled with what's on
the back and you turn to the back it
just says turn to the first five pages
there's nothing more and like it's your
move it's just pictures yeah
it's like the front is a head shot and
the back is just a picture of the back
of their head it's like that's just
really
it's choose
yeah whatever you get to makes no sense
it's a nonsense you always end up
killing yourself it's weird but there's
a silver lining at least jack dorsey is
happy well good for him he said elon's
goal of creating a platform that is
maximally trusted and broadly increase
inclusive is the right one what this is
the right path i believe it with
all my heart
i think he's just happy that he got to
cash out he was like i'm never
going to make any money on this no i
would just retire forever yeah i would
shave change my name take out the
ridiculous nose ring and move on yeah no
i that's i don't know i'm not giving uh
jack dorsey too much credit uh no i'm
not giving and you guys can comment
below why you think he's it's uh what is
it okay is it just been sorry if i've
been distracted you've been hearing that
weird noise
coming it's like it's coming from the
edit bay let's sell it can we check in
over there
[Music]
rick van winkle's finally waking up
dude
how long was i at
like
200 years
oh that was a rage
[Music]
last thing i remember is uh
wait
whatever that dwarf dave's not a dwarf
oh come on
oh thought this yeah it needs a little
bit of a trim uh not the drapes the
carpet
oh
you need
what the hell's manscaped it's a company
that provides skin safe tools for a
man's more
sensitive areas yeah and it leaves you
feeling hygienic and confident i like
that here try their new lawnmower 4.0
the lawnmower 4.0 is a fourth generation
trimmer for body groups with skin safe
replaceable ceramic guards and quiet
stroke technology it's waterproof and
has a wireless recharging system for its
high efficiency rechargeable battery the
lawnmower also has an led spotlight
do your groin a favor
all right we're really happy with uh our
sponsor i'm trying to get it in the
light here uh you can go to uh
manscape.com use the promo code crowder
uh 20 off your order they do free
worldwide shipping by the way this is
also uh it's testicular cancer awareness
month for april yeah those uh those
breast cancer ladies don't get to have
all the fun now do that yeah
what about uh what about a little
something for us here no there's never
been a major movement to save the balls
save the balls yeah
they both matter they do all i'm saying
is they all matter let's say save the
wave i think it's because you got to
come up with the nickname they're more
responsible for crimes than breasts well
that's probably true something about the
bell curve now they have the new
lawnmower testicular cancer society
edition uh and they're going to give a
50 000
to their longtime partner the testicular
cancer society so uh they have this new
i think it's we save balls edition yeah
uh the lawnmower 4. one thing i will say
about this look i i have you you know
that sometimes i've had to go into
costume and
shave uh everything and when i had
surgery everything there's a light on
this trimmer i've had a lot of trimmers
that really makes a difference huh where
well i'm just saying wherever you shave
there's a light that rakes across for
the same reason a light raking across
your your skin is unflattering yeah you
get to see everything that you miss and
also things that
no man should ever see it's why for the
ad read we wanted to make sure to
mention it because it really is like
it's impressive yeah it's pretty good it
actually makes a difference oh wow i had
no idea there was that mole with a hair
that's smiling at me by the way that
ceramic guard
yeah thank you manscape yeah
so oh yeah that is uh
oh boy
i don't have a bloodlust no no i was
gonna say i don't think we really have
time to talk about google right now no
uh so we were going you know what we're
gonna talk about this uh do you wanna
talk about on a mug club
sure or do we wanna still play what the
[ __ ] tomorrow week let's do it tomorrow
we got a whole segment okay do it
because it's a fun one yeah we have a
whole segment on uh on google right now
i don't know if you know this well
pretty cool just so you know along with
elon musk you know google if you guys
use google docs things like that they
launched a new initiative where they're
going to auto correct words that were
offensive and we run into it uh the
words aren't even necessarily offensive
no this is just again it's who
determines what's offensive
for example mankind that's all i'm going
to say mankind will be auto correct
where you see a little cursor it's just
back to that bent that paper clip is
that what was it gonzo bonzo buddy the
purple gorilla yeah except
paperclip has blue hair and it's yelling
at you exactly you're a white
supremacist right just googling yeah if
you wanted to ask jeeves but now it's
ask jess
ask jeffrey from befresh prince yeah
it's like i wanted to research uh said
did you mean sexual reassignment surgery
no no jeeves
jeff i just want to know if there's a
good pizza place i cut my paper clip on
a good penis removal please
so look uh if you guys are watching
right now we're gonna go uh to mug club
uh please do consider joining uh what
we're about today is what the flag these
are all uh new gender flags which of
course once upon a time would have never
been allowed on twitter but you know
what the good thing is we'll probably be
able to post some clips from mug club
short clips on twitter now without being
removed i bet you twitter won't even
remove us for a merchandise so hit the
like button leave a comment below the
winning comment gets pinned and a lock
of gerald's back care oh that was
youtube are you tired you have it timed
right now yeah i got it piss off
[Music]
hold on a second hold on one second here
this is you guys are experiencing what
i'm experiencing i'm very confused are
you playing what the flag are we not
because you're saying that uh we have a
problem with a mime token allen we we
may not have a mind but we'll have
someone in here to act out the genders
okay i don't know if i'm comfortable
because the mime helps the mime does
help that's the only reason i get any of
them we could we could play the game
make a mime talk
yeah that's a fun game this is loaded
yeah that's what i mean like we really
could have some fun
that's always the plan b just tie them
down and manscape 2.0 um
four four two point manscape him hook a
car battery up yes
so do we have a mom if not we can do the
google segment or do we want to uh
oh do we want to ask the audience which
one they prefer yeah hey guys okay you
know what you guys let us know but if
someone is someone we'll track right now
i feel like we made it we made a false
promise to youtube then well the thing
is i didn't realize that we didn't have
a mime so this is you know where uh
timeless yeah
someone missed their mark uh
do you guys want to see us to play what
the flagger he wants to talk to you
about google docs and google now uh
getting rid of offensive language on
google docs and what are they going to
do with excel this is going to screw the
accounting world that's going to mess
things up it really ties back into the
story we covered yesterday where the
european commission the dsa we were
talking about where they're going to say
every you know cloud computing internet
every internet sorry geez the internet
everybody yeah everything
everything
thank you dave everything that you put
out there now they're going to say no no
no this is this is now something that we
can block right so they're saying oh
this is just autocorrect to keep you
from being hateful really this means
you're just looking at more of my
information not that you weren't already
but now you're correcting it right yeah
it's i mean a soulless robot is telling
you like maybe you mean this so it's not
getting it accurate all the time which
is the best we could also just argue
about artificial intelligence because
while we were going through run through
this morning people got really heated
i think what was your support my point
is this you have all these nerds who are
talking about artificial intelligence
and they're acting like it's skynet and
ai is going to take over the world and
how dangerous it is because it stems
from elon musk it could i don't buy it
siri
google home right alexa they're just
glorified furbys they can't even they
can't even give you a news briefing they
don't get anything right